st's dark stuff everywhere I've met
Americans who were terrified to go to
the UK like am I going to get stabbed
I'm like dude like it's safer than here
that's pretty funny to think that though
I don't want to get stabbed by some of
funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
accent so RFK Jr has been caught in a
little Scandal we finally got the son of
a
[__] he's going down he's finally going
down this is what you get for not help
we got the
podcast we finally got him so uh he was
on Tik Tok as people do of course and he
was he was commenting on a big butted
[__] who was just like showing a video
yeah a big but you know SE it SE so
sometimes we all just you know we we're
on we we catch ourselves in certain
environments liking big butted or big
titty bites whatever you want whatever
you're into hey what's if you're looking
at it why can't you support and put the
heart button hit the like it's the
[__] easiest thing ever but but we we
don't always do it we're ashamed for the
RFK he's like oh yeah
baby oh yeah baby oh baby he says oh
honey let me milk that sh no he didn't
that would be a funny
comment no so what happened was he just
says like all right yay basically he has
hand claps yeah basically he's like Yay
good job he good job but the thing is
twering so there's people who found a
old Tik Tok video where this big buted
[__] is showing showing them cakes off
right yeah and them cakes is looking
good right and so RFK has contextualized
this as saying like hey guys what
actually happened is so I did I wasn't
even running for president yet when this
video got
AOW okay like oh
y so he said one of his staffers was
nice enough because when he was first
running for president right you can't
just go on Tik Tok and start doing live
streams you have to have a th followers
so he says one of my staffers was kind
enough to give me their Tik Tok account
and we just like changed the name and
turned it into RFK Tik Tok account so
then it it back posts everything that
the guy ever liked or said is now under
the RFK for president account that
actually makes sense it does make sense
it makes hell of
sense but people are saying that's a
bunch of [__] so that's the big
thing it's [__] dude if it's a big
buted [__] it's a it's [__] we all
love the big butted [__] I do my
wife's got a big old butt yeah zuie what
do you think about giant big butted bull
huge cakes I'm
Africa good I'm going to use that for
now I don't know what that means yeah
that doesn't that mean I like big butt
and I cannot lie people could you
explain can I explain yeah can you
expand I don't know if I can because I
don't know I don't know if it's genetic
I don't know if it's social I don't know
if it's I thought it was a known fact
would you give Tucker that answer I
thought it was a known fact that when
you go above the Mediterranean it's a
boob culture and when you go below the
Mediterranean it's a butt culture so
it's an
equator Regional that's why Brazilians
that explains my flavor yeah yeah
Brazilians all that South Asian it goes
that and then you go up boobs yeah yeah
makes sense but what if you like both
then does that mean you're right on the
you're probably more of the meridian
then you're greedy oh then you need to
chill out a little bit chill the [__]
out stop
overeating Ting you're on the Capricorn
line the in between that's world
domination [__] yeah Colleen what do
you think about giant ass I have one
good job expand on that expand on
that well you know I don't really know
what you mean by
expanding working out will expand it
yeah that was woke that was woke I like
that don't you want to president that
likes to [__] though what
[Applause]
what was it Clint that was Bill Clinton
no no Bill Clinton like the [__] all
right so RFK he works out all right and
he likes a butt here or there well you
don't want Clinton Clint's too [__] he's
[__] so much he can't do work right
but then like we got RFK who's
occasionally commenting hey nice butt
Trump just grabbing by the [__] that's
a different one right so I mean I mean
you want the leader of the Free World to
be a little horny you don't want them to
be
unhorny healthy testosterone and yeah
yeah yeah you don't want him so old that
he's not even motivated to do it anymore
and he's just like too tired but Joe
Biden will fall up some stairs for some
[__] I
heard I heard he I heard he'll fall all
the way up the stairs for
it that's a really good explanation
though I actually buy it I do too cuz to
a lot of people in politics they don't
know anything about social media and
then someone just gives them account uh
uh no it's the the permission thing cuz
cuz he couldn't do he couldn't do live
streaming so he he needed this oh so his
one of his uh team had a had one of his
team used to be horny and then they gave
him the account no longer horny like
that other story though it's more fun to
believe that it was him so it's so much
more fun thank you no thank you that's
what I'm saying bro that's exactly what
and that's not even the worst thing to
find that an old account even did like
that's not that bad like oh wow that's
not it's the heart eye
emoji the comment let's get into the
comments what are those I also like how
open he is with this past like just drug
addiction and all that stuff yeah if
he's going to tell us about that that it
makes him very very relatable and more
human and I think because he's like so
open about it's kind of like the whole
Eight Mile thing where he lays it all
out then it's kind of hard to find dirt
so they got to rip up the whole page at
the debate find any way to put something
on them yeah that makes him strangely
relatable yeah I'd say well it's just
honest I I think it's just honest really
you think he's going to be honest about
steroid use he's honest about everything
else he says he's a drug addict and all
his stuff yeah he's really strong if you
were a drug addict I don't think there
would be any problem with you saying you
did steroids cuz that's bar yeah he's
probably definitely on trt yeah but he's
also just athletic like you saw him do a
backflip off a cliff he did a backflip
yeah like so the cliff is like 30 or 40
ft High he does a back flip off the CL
cliff into the water making that the
determining factor and this was like 70
or something that's crazy dude I'm
voting for him man we will now have all
candidates do their backflip nobody
could backflip get it he's the only
President you know what's crazy is I
think that that would be more effective
than the current system I
think I think on average you would get
better leaders very back if you just had
a gym test yeah for sure hey you're
trailing in the PO luckily we got the
physical coming up I mean honestly I'm
not even joking if it was just like who
can bench more who can deadlift more
yeah they're physically more capable at
at that age is that us being like
doomers though or blackpilled are we
just like giving up if we if that's our
qualification I want a healthy vibrant
president dude look at the elections
over the past 12 years oh bro like look
at what the options have been 100% and
low key it's like you're kind of our
like commander and chief if you're like
capable and aware for some reason I
might trust you a little bit more yeah
and we liked Barack because he was
playing basketball too just showing a
little bit of physical prowess we're
like okay that's tight first George Bush
Jr was a cheerleader if he was on top of
the pyramid going America like that
would have been so much cooler in my
opinion this is I guess this is
controvery but I think Larry Bird was
blacker than Barack Obama dude like are
you [__] kidding me Barack Obama
watching him play basketball is like oh
Jesus Christ it's just politician
stiffness every
everywhere yeah nervousness strangeness
no I mean comparing to Larry Bird though
I mean Larry Bird's pretty uh he's loose
lar pretty good at
basketball kind of up there he's pretty
good at basketball great what about like
Austin Reeves or Barack Obama you know
what I mean who's Austin Reeves uh just
hit seven out of 10 three-pointers for
the Lakers he's him I have been betting
on NFL I don't give a [__] don't ask him
real football yeah thank you cuz
basketball's the fake football I've been
betting in losing at NFL recently thank
you very sorry thank you well there it
is Colleen what's your take on us big
booty [__] yeah that's my take such a
good take that a good take do you do you
have um I know that you're not
originally from the UK but do you have
like a sense of in investment and or
pride in UK politics I thought you were
going to just end with the UK in which
case I would have said yes UK politics
um I don't do you guys take pride in
American politics now I
do now it's super our favorite
interesting but um yeah I don't it used
to be boring though I don't take I don't
take pride in it I take pride some pride
in the UK being a br being from there
being a citizen but um politics is trash
man I don't like politics I wonder I
talk about it sometimes why come you're
so mired in it I'm not but you kind of
are you're kind of like synonymous just
aware yeah I don't talk about politics
that much like you'll you you'll almost
never see me talking about Democrats and
Republicans and tories and so what do
you like Democrats or Republicans I'm
not saying you do it I'm saying what
people do to you they they they throw
you in the pool yeah because people who
are politically Super Hyper political
minded yeah um view everything
politically right it's why they're
sitting there watching the podcast like
trying to work out if you're on the
right or the left or if you're woke or
if you're anti-woke it's like they want
to know which Camp to put you inly and
it's
like but do you when you when that
happens to you are you like I'm going to
measure my speech next time I'm no I
don't care yeah no I don't care there's
another thing that I keep uh I've
started to always keep in mind now which
is that um
1% of the people who are on social media
create pretty much all of the content
and another 10% do all the commenting so
90% of the people who are on any social
media platform are just like watching
listening whatever but not interacting
and engaging so when you keep those
numbers in mind it's sort of like
massively you can see how people get
things massively skewed right cuz you
might get like 10 comments on a video
saying like and you're like oh my gosh
like everyone hated the video or
everyone and you're like Wait no that's
like 10% of like a a small percent of
10% of like a smaller percent is like
actually or or when people think oh
everyone is talking about such and such
no it's not everyone it's 10 losers it's
like seven people with prominent foll
who are starting a conversation and it
seems like every the people that are
affected they don't even look at the 300
positive comments they say two negative
ones and go oh they hate the video Yeah
and and by the way this is this is also
why when when people spend way too much
time on social media you you can get the
perception that everything is so much
worse than it is yeah yeah yeah because
by definition if something makes the
news or something goes viral by
definition it's an anomaly so people can
think oh my gosh like like for example
me being an LA right now if I'm like hey
guys I'm going to La half the comments
are going to be make sure you got your
bulletproof vest be careful don't step
through get out of that City you know
what because every time they see La it's
like people looting and shoplifting and
some sh it's some so many gunmen are
outside right now plus the algorithm
pushes your interest so you're going to
keep watching the things that are going
to be more your take so just an echo
chamber of your I mean it the things
that you mentioned do happen but also
you could grow up in parts of LA where
you're blind to all of that where people
that's what people don't know bad stuff
happens everywhere in the world like
there's there's dark stuff everywhere I
I've met Americans who are terrified to
go to the UK like am I going to get
stabbed I'm like dude like it's safer
than here that's pretty funny to think
that though man like what are you what
are you so concern like these things are
not impossible right like you can get
hit by lightning but to never leave your
house because you're afraid of that is
kind of goofy so yeah anyway just a
random thought love it I don't want to
get stabbed by some of funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
accent